a todos en el vídeo se les realizó una
prueba de alcohol y 19 antes de grabar
cuántas ganas tienes de tener sexo
muchísimas ganas muchísimas muchísimas
ganas le pedimos a la audiencia que nos
enviaran preguntas íntimas vergonzosas y
calientes para que extremen yo sola se
respondieran basándose en sus
experiencias
esto va a ser interesante
cómo definirías la virginidad
esto me hace pensar si estamos hablando
de la heteronormativa es muy complicado
el pen y la vagina me siento como un
niño de dos años pero hablando del flexo
con penetración ya sea con el pene la
lengua con un juguete o algo así es una
pregunta interesante porque si él es la
definición técnica estoy bastante seguro
de que dice que incluso el sexo oral se
considera perder la virginidad y lo
mismo suelen decir acerca de los pesos
lo que sea que con sientas es más o
menos lo que define tu propia virginidad
soy un hombre de fe y por lo tanto soy
un creyente definitivamente veo el sexo
como una responsabilidad la abstinencia
incluso va más allá de eso incluyen no
poder mirar a una chica con lujuria
mirarla de manera sexual hay que
mantener los ojos puros cuántas ganas
tienes de tener sexo muchísimas ganas
muchísimas muchísimas ganas puede que
sea una adolescente pero no pero no soy
fogosa para ser sinceros nunca he tenido
la necesidad o las ganas no ha hecho
nada no he tenido novio
y ni siquiera he dado mi primer beso y
no tengo prisa en la escala de cuan
caliente estoy no estoy tan caliente
pero definitivamente tiene que suceder
tiene que pasar es algo que espero con
ansias así una vez que ese momento
suceda
va a ser realmente increíble pero he
oído que hay un vínculo y no quiero
adquirir uno cuando no estoy preparado
para ello de hecho también he visto
mucho drama por ello por eso en mi caso
digo que no quiero formar parte de ese
drama siento que las únicas veces que
realmente pienso en una relación
romántica o el sexo es cuando lo veo en
una película pienso oh mira eso y luego
estoy solo en el sofá pensando esto
sería genial porque eres virgen
honestamente es que simplemente no he
tenido oportunidad crecí en una familia
cristiana que
cree en la abstinencia si tengo sexo me
iré al infierno es la única vez que voy
a hablar de eso si amo jesús pero
también sé que voy a hacer una salvaje
cuando pierda mi virginidad no solo
mostraré a nadie sino a mi marido solo
digo siempre tuve miedo porque mis
padres eran jóvenes cuando me tuvieron
así que era algo que no quería repetir a
mi gemelo y yo fuimos agredidos así que
soy un poco más cuidados al respecto
supongo es decir creo que soy como soy
porque he pasado por lo que he pasado yo
soy cristiano y por una gran parte de mi
vida creí que el sexo prematrimonial era
un pecado estoy en esta etapa intermedia
donde intento entender leo libros y
tengo conversaciones con las personas a
medida que se investiga más al respecto
las personas se dan cuenta de que lo que
se creía que estaba condenado no lo está
exactamente dice has tenido alguna vez
un orgasmo soy un hombre ya sabes me
quedo corto debo responderlos y emitirlo
[Risas]
no no lo he tenido lo cual es supongo
probablemente la razón por la que estoy
tan ansiosa por eso porque nunca lo he
tenido en la escuela las personas
siempre se burlaban de los que se
masturbaban todo el tiempo así que pensé
que algo estúpido pero sinceramente
nunca lo hice hasta que cumplí 18 años
no creo que realmente supiera lo que
estaba haciendo solo sabía que iba a
hacer algo y que se sentiría muy bien y
pensé debería hacerlo más mi mamá se
ofreció a comprarme mi primer vibrador
me dijo que yo ya era mayor
independiente y que tenía necesidades
que intentara que no costará 200 dólares
pero que me compraría mi primer vibrador
así que si ella es increíble prefieres
que tu primera vez sea con una virgen o
con alguien experimentado
bueno no he pensado en eso alguien con
experiencia quiero decir una de las dos
debería saber lo que hace no siento que
estoy bien de cualquier manera no sé
creo que está todo el tema de la
inseguridad estaría constantemente
comparándome con las parejas anteriores
de esa otra persona o estaría pensando
si estoy haciendo esto bien sinceramente
preferiría que mi primera vez fuera con
otra persona virgen solo porque ambos no
sabríamos que estamos haciendo creo que
se trata más de la persona sabe si
realmente estás enamorado de ella o si
tienes una conexión con ella no debe
importar alguna vez te has avergonzado
de ser virgen
tengo 22 años y siento que a medida de
que me hago más vieja se me hace algo
raro no voy a mentir a veces me
avergüenzo de ello si hay una estigma
contra las vírgenes que eres torpe que
eres rara o que hay algo malo en ti no
puedes hacer contacto visual no puedes
mantener una conversación aunque yo no
sudo ninguna de esas cosas esa no soy yo
mi experiencia es que cuando tuve citas
en el pasado se tomaron el tiempo para
conocerme y ver mi brillante
personalidad hasta que descubren esta
parte que
es una parte muy pequeña de mí y
entonces todo mi ser está enmarcado por
esa cosa trató de establecer mis
expectativas por adelantado al principio
dicen que lo respetan cuanto más dura la
relación intentan presionarte un sujeto
me llamó a mitad de la noche durante
cinco horas y me dijo que el
cristianismo no era real que dios no era
real que estaba haciendo el ridículo si
terminamos que es incómodo a veces si
hay personas alrededor que están
tratando de presumir todo el tiempo
presumiendo de cuántas veces han tenido
sexo ni siquiera quiere explicarles por
qué así que es mejor simplemente decir
una mentira piadosa si he tenido sexo
sabes creo que lo cuestionaran más si
les dices que todavía eres virgen
simplemente mientes y les dices que no
soy virgen cuando estábamos en una
fiesta o algo así te sientes como tú
eres el virgen te conservador sabes pero
creo que con el tiempo aprendí a
aceptarlo tengo 29 años esta es una de
esas cosas que una vez que llegas a
cierto punto las aceptas si voy a llegar
a los 40 años de edad virgen estoy bien
con eso has tenido la oportunidad de
perder la virginidad pero no lo has
hecho si he tenido la oportunidad si he
tenido la oportunidad de hacerlo
si no no era tan sociable era muy mala
para hablar con otras personas también
soy muy mala coquetea siempre hay
personas que te escriben por mensaje y
preguntan hola quieres tener sexo
conmigo y yo solo pienso no aléjate si
si estaba en eso y algo me decía que
simplemente no valía la pena fue después
del baile de invierno que salí con un
chico el término y él
quería continuar y eso pero yo estaba
bien así y alguna vez te arrepientes de
no haber corrido esos riesgos la verdad
es que no porque muchas de esas
oportunidades serán en una situación de
fiesta yo estaba ebrio o ellos estaban
ebrios no fueron situaciones románticas
en las que hubiera mucha intimidad y te
la perdieras porque tenías miedo no me
perdí de nada ves porno cuando era más
joven
veía porno en tumblr y tenía que
asegurarme que no hubiera nadie mirando
cerraba mi puerta le pasaba la llave y
me aseguraba de que nadie supiera lo que
sucedía dios mío es tan incómodo solo
pienso lo están haciendo en frente a la
cámara
no veo porno ahora pero creo que hubo
una gran parte de mi vida en que todos
los días veía porno creo que si llego al
punto de la adicción tuve este constante
recordatorio de que esto era muy malo
era muy malo y me castigaba por ello así
que no se lo dices a nadie porque
solamente asumes que ninguno de tus
amigos ve porno el porno también es algo
en lo que incluso yo me estoy
replanteando mucho a veces me inclino
más hacia él
no sé si el porno es malo cuando mi
punto de vista cambio ya no
ya no había nada contra lo que estuviera
luchando así que solo deje de perder
siento que si puedes diferenciar que el
porno no es la vida real de hecho no lo
es el porno es estrictamente una cosa de
entretenimiento mientras no consumas con
moderación no sería un problema tienes
miedo por tu primera vez
si totalmente el hecho de que alguien
más solo tenga esta intimidad contigo y
revelar tanto de ti mismo a otra persona
es muy intimidante yo no porque
simplemente si confío en esta persona
entonces no debería tener miedo tengo
miedo de que no cumpla mis expectativas
creo que he tenido tanto tiempo para
fantasear con ello tengo estas visiones
de oh dios mío vamos a estar en sábanas
de satén con pétalos de rosas y velas lo
he exagerado mucho mi cabeza tengo miedo
de no sentir ningún placer porque existe
el enorme estereotipo de que el placer
es para el chico y la chica no tiene
nada
soy fan sexual y si termino teniendo una
pareja masculina y eso sucede sería algo
terrible he oído de amigos que no va a
ser muy placentero sé que va a ser
incómodo pero espero que sea con la
persona adecuada para poder reírnos
después
me veo a mí mismo después de la boda a
donde volvamos a la habitación y luego
tengamos este momento especial donde en
realidad esto es algo que creo que puede
ser sorprendente para muchas personas es
que me gustaría rezar esto sonará como
una locura porque estoy loco pero creo
que sería una cosa hermosa hermosa al
ser capaz de rezar mientras lo hacemos
parece una locura pero creo que es tan
hermoso de verdad no se educación sexual
síguenos en instagram
jubilee media para enviarnos sus
preguntas para episodios a futuro
gracias por mirar
jubilee aumentando la empatía
[Música]